Avengers: Endgame resolved lots of questions
that went unanswered after Avengers: Infinity
War... but it didn't fully discuss the deaths
of all of the characters who died pre-Snap,
namely Vision.
Speaking during a recent Q&A event, director
Joe Russo finally addressed Vision's fate.
Consider yourself warned: Lots of spoilers
ahead!
So, who didn't survive Infinity War?
Loki died early on, after Thanos strangled
him.
Later, Thanos sacrificed Gamora in order to
obtain the Soul Stone.
But thanks to all the time-travel woven throughout
the story, both characters eventually appear
in Endgame.
However, Vision doesn't.
This left viewers wondering if the android
would ever be returning, or if he's truly
gone for good.
Speaking at the Q&A event An Evening with
Joe Russo, the filmmaker was more than happy
to discuss Vision's fate…
But you might be less than thrilled to hear
what he has to say.
The bad news: Vision was definitely killed
in Infinity War when Thanos yanked the Mind
Stone out of his forehead.
Judging by a comment from Russo, that plot
point won't be undone anytime soon:
"Vision?
He's dead as far as I know."
Co-director Anthony Russo agreed with audiences
everywhere that it was heartbreaking to watch
Vision perish at the end of Infinity War,
telling Wired in 2018,
"One of the most tragic moments in the movie
and one of our favorite moments of the movie,
of course, is when she has to take his life
in order to stop Thanos from getting the stone."
Then, it was doubly upsetting when the Mad
Titan reversed that effort to inflict the
damage himself.
At the end of the day, Vision's death was
incredibly impactful and is probably best
left untouched.
But the android's terrible fate goes one step
further; Anthony Russo noted that it was all
probably even a little bit worse than what
we saw on screen, noting that actor Paul Bettany
interprets Vision as...
"... just someone who's seeking to understand
humanity, and I think that with that final
gesture, Vision really achieved full humanity."
If Vision finally became effectively human
in that moment, the fact that Thanos used
the Time Stone to undo Scarlet Witch's efforts
and kill him himself is even more devastating.
Ultimately, if the powers that be decide to
rebuild Vision, it could potentially undermine
his whole story arc, and diminish much of
the meaning behind his death.
To complicate matters, Marvel Studios president
Kevin Feige revealed in April 2019 that the
upcoming Disney+ series WandaVision and the
future MCU movies are linked, saying,
And perhaps that goes both ways.
If the MCU movies have an impact on the forthcoming
Disney+ shows just as much as the series will
impact future films, Vision's death should
influence WandaVision's story.
On the flip side, if WandaVision features
a Vision who's very much alive, it might mean
he has a place in Phase 4 of the MCU.
Neither Disney nor Marvel have confirmed how
that's possible in the context of the MCU,
but Scarlet Witch actress Elizabeth Olsen
did tease that WandaVision would have a specific
time setting.
"They showed a photo of us in the '50s?
And I think that's a good teaser?"
Right now, anything can happen.
Whether Marvel decides to keep him dead or
ultimately decides to revive him...
"I am on the side of life."
... we can at least be fairly confident that
we haven't seen the last of Vision.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.